I think it's very important to be able  to see things from not only China's  perspective but also for them to see it  from America's perspective and to  realize that uh if there is a war a  military war it will be  um the worst war we've ever had because  the technologies have advanced and to be  able to deal with that well so I guess  there's a lot to talk about in terms of  China I would emphasize the importance  of uh avoiding  um the wars  um and there are five types of Wars  right right and they get to get  progressively more difficult there's a  trade War a technology War a  geopolitical influence War a capital war  and a military war and they all can go  together